le match était censée se terminer hier
il ira finalement en prolongation
c'est ce qu'ont annoncé londres et
bruxelles les négociateurs du bric sites
vont donc poursuivre leurs discussions
rien n'est encore joué a déclaré ursula
von der leyen dans une brève conférence
de presse juste après son entretien
téléphonique avec boris johnson johnson
j'ai eu un appel téléphonique
constructif et utile avec le premier
ministre boris johnson
nous avons discuté des principaux sujets
non résolus nos équipes de négociation
travaillé jour et nuit ces derniers
jours et malgré l'épuisement
après presque un an de négociations et
malgré le fait que les délais étaient et
maintes fois manqué nous pensons tous
deux qu'il est responsable
à ce stade ci de faire un effort
supplémentaire nous avons donc chargé
nos négociateurs de poursuivre les
pourparlers et de voir si un accord peut
être conclu
même à ce stade tardif les négociations
se poursuivent ici à bruxelles at des
slate states dany coaching coacher une
princesse officiellement le royaume uni
a déjà quitté l'union depuis le 31
janvier dernier
mais en cette période de transition qui
doit prendre fin le 31 décembre prochain
les britanniques sont toujours sous le
coup des règles européennes
ils n'ont donc pour le moment pas
abandonner le marché unique et l'union
douanière
faute d'accord entre les deux parties
avant la fin du mois les échanges seront
régies par les règles de lohan c'est
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
cela signifie entre autres le retour des
barrières douanières et tarifaires mais
alors qu'est ce qui coince concrètement
entre le 1 et le royaume uni
le dossier de la pêche est l'un des
blocages majeurs lui eux souhaite
toujours avoir accès aux eaux
britanniques riche en poissons alors que
londres en tongs contrôler cet accès est
instaurée par exemple des quotas pour
les pêcheurs européens en prévision d'un
odile
ministère de la défense du royaume a
annoncé avoir mobilisé quatre navires
militaires pour protéger ses eaux
si certains y voient une anticipation
légitime d'autres au contraire craignent
pour l'image du pays
il est tout à fait approprié que la
royal navy protège nos aussi la position
est que nous sommes un état souverain et
que le gouvernement ne veut pas voir là
bas des bateaux de pêche dans notre pays
nous nous retrouvons face à la
perspective de voir notre royal navy
déjà débordés se confronter à un proche
allié de l'otan sur les droits de pêche
nous devons construire des alliances et
non les briser sur le volet commercial
là aussi ça coince les européens exigent
du royaume uni certaines garanties pour
éviter toute concurrence déloyale en lui
laissant un accès à son marché unique
il souhaite s'assurer que les
entreprises britanniques et respecte
bien les mêmes normes fiscales
sanitaires et environnementales que
celle réclamée par bruxelles aux
entreprises européennes
dernier point de crispation qui pour
trancher en cas de différend entre les
deux parties une fois le divorce
prononcé dans le texte de retrait ce
point est censé être gérée par la cour
de justice de l'union européenne
mais le royaume uni ne l'entendent pas
de cette oreille et s'y oppose au nom de
sa souveraineté
les prolongations au vent donc durer
mais elles ne pourront pas s'éterniser
quelques jours au maximum a averti dans
le jdd clément bonne le secrétaire
d'état français aux affaires européennes